The Islamic Republic of Iran warns it is
one step away from building a nuclear
weapon that could be unleashed quickly
on Israel or the United States. Remarks
posted to an Iranian Revolutionary Guard
social media site recently boasted the
regime could quote turn New York into
ruins and hell. Here to provide some
insights on this is author Raymond
Ibrahim. His new book is Defenders of
the West, The Christian Heroes Who Stood
Against Islam.
Raymond, Western leaders keep trying to
reach an accommodation with Iran, but
I'm assuming you believe it's futile.
Why do you believe a war between the
West and Iran is probably inevitable?
Because it has been going on since time
immemorial. With the rise of Islam in
the 7th century, whether it was a Sunni
or Shia manifestations, they essentially
launched what they called and understood
as a jihad on the rest of the non-Muslim
world, which a joint which at the time
was actually mostly Christian. And so
and they conquered and they continued
conquering until they swallowed up three
quarters of the original Christian
territory till Europe was all you had
left and that was even constantly
bombarded. And Iran's is is governed by
a theocracy. So that to me is ultimately
the most troubling aspect. And the
recent news that Al-Qaeda leader Ayman
al-Zawahiri was killed in a US drone
strike, that's just one man, but I guess
there may be thousands of Al-Qaeda
jihadists in Afghanistan now based on
your research.
What's your prediction about what will
happen in Afghanistan now? I'm assuming
the Taliban, other Islamic extremists
view this is only a temporary setback.
After all, they were kind of able to
drive the US crusaders out of
Afghanistan. What do you think?
Yeah, you know, I mean, the the the
small news, the insignificant but
political symbolic news is you killed
Ayman al-Zawahiri who was one of the two
faces of 9/11, him him and Osama bin
Laden, but he really was a kind of
marginalized character right now. He was
in his early 70s. You just you didn't
hear much about him. He's just a
propagandistic figure and so forth. And
um I've been studying this because if
you go back from the first killings of
Abu Abu Musab al-Zarqawi, if you
remember him, he was original face of
ISIS. And then, you know, all the way
down all these various leaders,
including Osama bin Laden. I remember
when Osama bin Laden died, you know,
Peter Bergen and other uh CNN analysts
like
Fareed Zakaria, they came up and
literally said, "Well, we can now
declare the war on terror is over."
Because as if as if it's all embodied in
one man, but it's not. Um you know, it's
like uh to give it a quick analogy, you
know, the Hercules myth where he fights
the hydra monster and every time he cuts
off one head, two more sprout out in its
place. And that's really what's going
on. It doesn't matter if you kill this
or that terrorist as as we've seen. If
you go back, you know, that you've
always had heads of jihad. Arguably, we
can begin with Muhammad himself, a
prophet. And even he died and the jihad
continued. So, I think it's more
important to understand the existential
ideological nature of the war we're in
and stop being caught up again for
political points and symbolism on on the
Biden administration's behalf with
killing this or that leader. Okay, in
your book you look at eight heroes who
defended Christendom. In the first
chapter, I found your account of Godfrey
and the first crusade fascinating and I
don't think the average person realizes
that the first crusade was actually a
response to the slaughter of innocent
Christians, many of them women and
children. Tell us more about this.
Exactly, Gary. Again, the problem is we
always when we hear about any kind of
religious conflict uh Christian Muslim
conflict, the historical aspect
immediately what comes to mind most
Americans and Westerners is the
Crusades. And then the Crusades are
presented in a vacuum. We're not told
that, well, they are actually responding
to centuries worth of attacks from
Muslims in the name of Islam on fellow
Christians. And include and right before
the uh Crusades, you actually had the
Turks just devastating Anatolia, Asia
Minor, which is today Turkey, killing
according to the sources hundreds of
thousands of Christians, burning
literally over thousands, many thousands
of churches, transforming them into
mosques, and that's what initiated the
call of the First Crusade. And one of
the first Crusaders is, of course,
Godfrey of Bouillon, the Duke.
And we have time for another one. Fast
forward to the mid-15th century. How
about the hero of Albania, George
Castriot, also known as Skanderbeg? Uh
he suffered betrayal even from his own
nephew Hamza, but he enjoyed many battle
victories during more than two decades.
Uh when he and his troops were vastly
outnumbered, I guess, by invading Turks,
the Turks again. Tell us more about him.
Absolutely. All of these characters, I
should just say, you know, I I read
about eight and beginning with Godfrey
and then we end up uh
with Skanderbeg and even Vlad the
Impaler. And I try to give a corrective,
you know, of the true nature of who he
is and who he was. And by the way,
Godfrey's one of the most interesting
characters. Um you know, very colorful
life along the First Crusade. But he's
also famous for saying he became the
first king of the of the kingdom of
Jerusalem, but he refused to be called
king. And he said, "I refuse to wear a
crown of gold where my savior wore a
crown of thorns." So, very pious men who
were driven by just war theory. Now, you
fast forward um you know, about four or
five centuries and now you have
Skanderbeg in Albania and now we have a
whole different manifestation of Islamic
jihad. You have the Ottoman Turks going
into the Balkans and devastating it and
so forth. And his life is really
amazing. He was actually kidnapped as a
youth, trained to be an Islamic slave
soldier, rose to the highest echelons of
the military due to his prowess,
and then waged war for over a quarter of
a century against the Ottomans by
defending his his tiny nation. And and
the odds were ridiculous. Usually, he'd
have 10,000 men, the Ottomans would have
over 100,000, but he actually beat them
in every single confrontation for for a
quarter of a century. Um and he's one of
the most really They call him the
Albanian Braveheart. So, really all of
these uh characters are fascinating and
it's amazing that we don't have movies
about them, but I think I know why
because they were actually very much
driven by their Christian piety, believe
it or not. And Hollywood won't touch
that with a 10-ft pole. Okay, a book
that should be on the reading list for
every world history buff and in colleges
and universities. The book is Defenders
of the West, the Christian heroes who
stood against Islam. Raymond Ibrahim,
thanks for providing those insights. We
appreciate it, Raymond.
Thanks very much, Jerry.
Bring back
the fire.
the fire
>> [music]
>> in the
righteous name.